[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à tableémission où on parle
cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie et aussi un peu politique et
cette semaine nous recevons Valérie
massonalmotte bonjour bonjour et avec
moi pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Valérie
maçonelmot bonjour vous êtes
paléoclimatologue c'est-à-dire que vous
étudiez les climats passés et leurs
variations alors intéressant au moment
où la COP 28 s'est ouverte à Dubaï cette
ville qui climatise ces terrasses alors
vous êtes aussi directrice de recherche
au CEA le Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et vous avez été co-présidente
d'un groupe du GC jusqu'en juillet
dernier date à laquelle le bureau a été
renouvelé en 2022 vous avez été classé
parmi les 100 personnalités les plus
influentes du monde par le magazine Time
alors promier Jean-Pierre vient à vélo
et et et moi je prends le ROR pas pas de
souci là-dessus euh vous êtes celle en
tout cas que le président et tout le
gouvernement consulte après la canicule
de 2022 une formation expresse de 30
minutes et des entretiens bilatéraux
avec les ministres pour leur dire quoi
pour leur dire que la France doit
doubler son rythme de baisse des
émissions de gaz à fait de serre pour
respecter l'accord de Paris alors
évidemment après avoir dit ça et bien il
faut un menu exemplaire he exactement un
vrai menu végétarien avec des légumes de
saison Brigitte du chou romanesco
butternut purée de poisiche et en salade
et en dessert plutôt une salade de
fruits dans le dessous des plats
l'élevage fortement émetteur de gaz à
effet de ser faut-il se passer de la
viande dans les pieds dans le plat la
France au régime sec des villages dans
le sud frappés par la sécheresse sont
approvisionnés en eau par camion citerne
reportage à suivre allez on passe à
table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence alors Valérie maçon Delm je
voulais vous dire que j'ai fait un
épouvantable cauchemar j'ai rêvé qu'avec
Brigitte on recevait en pleine COP 28
l'ex catron du GC acronyme signifiant
guinfre irréductible éternel et carboné
un groupuscule d'ultra non pas identi
mais culinaire dans ce cauchemar les
réseaux sociaux étaient déchaînés contre
ces apôtres de la bouffe du monde d'hier
qui ont eu le culot de réclamer ici à la
table de LCP des côtes de bœuf gonflé
aux hormones des poulets gavés aux
géules protéiné élevés dans des géantes
batteries chinoises je me suis réveillé
Brigitte en sursaut quand des monceaux
de fraise méga carboné du Chili étit
servis en trans j'ai soudain réalisé que
JF je signifiait Groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat ouf pour notre image mais sur la
table oups on est passé subitement de
l'orgie alimentaire hérétique au repas
de la cantoche subventionné par une
mairie écolo des légumes de saison chou
romanesco et une purée de pois chiche en
guise de protéin alors certes cette
présentation est volontairement
caricaturale pour illustrer la bataille
radicalisée autour de notre assiette de
demain alors dites-nous franchement ce
plat-l c'est la recette pour bien
vieillir en fait c'est un un plat je
pense qui est bien équilibré h avec de
tout hein des fibres des légumineuses
donc des protéines végétales et ça fait
partie en fait des choses qui permettent
de vivre longtemps en bonne santé et de
réduire l'empreinte de carbone et ça
fait partie en fait des leviers d'action
qui sont importants pour à la fois en
fait agir en terme de santé publique
mais aussi en fait avoir un système
alimentaire qui soit plus durable euh
parce que c'est un enjeu majeur et dans
le monde le système alimentaire c'est 30
% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
et c'est pas seulement des enjeux climat
en fait on a 800000 mil de personnes qui
souffrent de de malnutrition et de faim
2 milliards de personnes qui souffrent
de maladiie chroniques lié au surpoids
et à l'obésité donc on voit qu'on touche
à des enjeux majeurs en fait he pour
pour la soutenabilité dans son ensemble
mais alors Valérie maçonalm c'est un
menu politiquement correct là que vous
nous proposez vous mangez toujours comme
ça moi j'espère moi je suis devenue
végétarienne il y il y a quelques années
et je pense qu'en fait j'espère surtout
que c'est bon parce qu'en fait cuisiner
essentiellement à base de plantes c'est
un vrai défi ça demande en fait
d'arriver à sublimer leû des légumes le
goût des légumineuses par exemple et
c'est plus un défi plus grand pour
beaucoup de cuisiniers d'arriver à le
faire bien donc on voit des choses qui
avancent qui sont intéressantes vous
vous avez donc choisi d'être
végétarienne il y a quelques années
qu'est-ce qui a été le déclic est-ce que
vous vous êtes dit c'est le climat
j'imagine le le dérèglement climatique
l'emprinte carbone où il y avait
vraiment cette envie de de mieux manger
aussi d'être en bonne santé il y a un
peu de tout mais donc dans ma vie
personnelle j'essaie de me mettre plus
en cohérence dans ma vie professionnelle
aussi entre la la manière dont on vit et
les enjeux en fait d'arriver à alléger
finalement le l'empreinte
environnementale que l'on a et donc dans
ma démarche familiale ça a fait partie
en fait des choix à un moment donné qui
sont devenu voilà une une pratique au
quotidien donc toute la famille s'est
mis non non en fait on a tout un spectre
de choix et donc du coup en fait on
apprend à cuisiner un peu à la carte où
voilà ceux qui veulent manger de la
viande de la charcut pris le fond ceux
qui n'en veulent pas ou un autre choix y
a de la toérance autour de la table oui
parce que c'est un moment de plaisir de
convivialité puis de liberté évidemment
vous avez réclamer des légumes de saison
est-ce que vous êtes content avec ce
qu'il y a dans votre assiette il y a du
chour romanesco là c'est c'est joli
buttern et puis alors il y a assez
légumineus lentillle et poischiche on
les associe pas tout le temps on fait
plutôt lentillle ou poischiche non en
fait ça ressemble à la manière dont on
se nourrit depuis des siècles et des
milliers d'années de manière vraiment
durable notamment autour de la
Méditerranée où les légumineuses font
partie en fait de de des plats habituels
et même à l'époque simplement de mon
arrière- grand-mère la viande c'était un
luxe en fait on en mangeait pas deux
fois par jour ou tous les jours et donc
c'est simplement revenir aussi à une
forme de bon sens où on cherche en fait
un équilibre et puis surtout que ce soit
bon et nutritif en méitérané on mange du
poisson aussi ça arrive fréquemment que
il enfin il y a pas que des menus
végétariens quand même non non non
l'idée c'est pas d'imposer quoi que ce
soit mais c'est simplement de de
s'interroger sur voilà trouver un juste
équilibre entre ce qu'on aime manger les
enjeux de santé les enjeux de
préservation des revenus des
agriculteurs de la production agricole
et ça tombe bien en fait en France on
fait aussi des lentilles des Poischich
on fait des légumes de saison c'est une
vraie privation pour vous ou ça l'a été
en tout cas de se priver de viande ou où
en fait finalement vous n'aimiez pas
tellement ça ça a été une évolution
régulière donc c'était non non j'ai pas
je vois pas du tout ça comme une
privation c'est l'inverse c'est penser
autrement la façon de se nourrir se
faire plaisir en mangeant moi j'aime
bien manger en fait hein faut le dire
mais autrement et du coup c'est un choix
de défi je trouve d'arriver à faire
autrement on goûte onûens on parle
souvent vous parliez du on parle souvent
aussi parliez de la Méditerranée on
parle souvent du régime crétois pour
vieillir longtemps que c'est le régime
très sain avec du poisson de l'huile
d'olive celui-ci il est encore plus sain
que le régime crétois c'est encore P
pasvaluer je peux pas évaluer parce
qu'en fait c'est pas un plat mais c'est
vraiment le fait de diversifier son
alimentation à l'échelle de la semaine à
l'échelle du mois et en réalité beaucoup
de personnes qui sont soucieux des deux
c'est-à-dire l'empreinte
environnementale privilégier aussi la
production agricole de proximité
française il y a des enjeux majeurs hein
sur le les revenus des agriculteurs et
et manger sain qui font le choix c'est
pas systématique mais c'est de remplacer
à un moment donné un repas par une offre
végétale et par exemple la cantine où je
vais manger le le midi il y a toujours
une offre alternative et le le le le le
l'intendant en fait he me disait que
c'est maintenant à peu près 30 % des
plats qui sont choisis comme ça quand on
a le choix et que c'est bon mais c'est
bon ou c'est juste quelques légumes
posés sur
non mais là c'est forcment bon c'est
chez Françoise qui a cuisiné donc c'est
forcément excellent ça manque un tout
petit peu de sel mais ça c'est pas bon
le non plus pour la santé mais j'aurais
bien salé et les poischiches alors ils
sont un peu je voulais vous parler des
poisiches mais là ils sont sous forme de
purée alors là c'est plutôt du homos on
retrouve dans les pays du MoyenOrient du
Proche Orient trois choses à savoir du
coup en attendant sur le comme ça vous
pouvez goûter le plat et après vous nous
dites c'est un un éliment santé riche en
fibres en minéraux et en vitamines mais
il est aussi très protéiné et pauvre en
matière grasse et rassasiant donc il est
très utile dans un régime végétarien on
le trouve toute l'année cuit en bocal et
en conserve dans ces cas-là il suffit de
le faire réchauffer s'il est sec c'est
un peu plus compliqué parce qu'il faut
le faire tremper toute une nuit ou alors
1 heure dans une eau très très chaude
bouillante ensuite il faut bien rincer
les petits pois pour enlever la petite
la petite peau qui est autour avant de
lancer la vraie cuisson qui peut durer
quand même encore une heure et demi hein
donc si vous aimez vraiment les bons
pois chiches de nos campagnes sec il
faut y penser un un peu à l'avance si il
se mange froid en salade avec des
oignons du cumin il est mixé en purée
comme ça c'est le houmous mais aussi
chaud dans un curry indien avec du lait
de coco et puis dans un couscous ou même
avec des pâtes ça paraît comme ça un peu
bizarre mais c'est très bon c'est une
recette de Calabre alors c'est peut-être
un peu plus lourd oui mais vous avez
moitié de pâte et un peu de de
poischiche mais protéin et pâtte c'est
pas mauvais c'est très bon c'est P
Valérie malmot est-ce que ça vous plaît
très bon il y a une herbe je sais pas si
de la coriandre ou quelque chose qui est
parfumé qui qui est très bonne al il y a
une autre recette qui est moins légère
de couscous en fait on les met dans une
plaque avec un peu d'huile d'olive au
four on met du paprika ou une épice ça
fait comme des chips un peu c'est c'est
très bon et puis le houousse en apéritif
avec des petits légumes crus c'est
agréable en fait et la farine de
poischiche aussi avec les Panis la soca
à Nice voilà une tradition
méditerranéenne qu'on voit à Nice
délicieuse alors est-ce que vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est pas toujours
facile de de bien cuisiner avec sans
protéines végétal animal pardon animal
ça veut dire que il faut quoi qu il faut
des sauces il faut des herbes il faut il
faut agrémenter C ces légumes quand même
relever le goût des légumes en fait le
mettre en valeur le relever pour pas que
ce soit fade voilà mais pas forcément
avec du sel comme le disait Jean-Pierre
non mais jouer ce qui est très joli
aussi c'est ce qu'on voit là ce qu'on
voit dans la culture par exemple
végétarienne en Inde par exemple ou bien
en Amérique du Sud c'est jouer aussi sur
les couleurs pour que ce soit
appétissant en fait donc jouer sur un
mélange de couleur il y en a 5 ou si là
dans l'assiette c'est très joli en fait
alors moi j'aurais bien mis un petit peu
d'huile d'olive mais du coup là l'indice
calorique il est plus fort oui mais un
tout petit peu mais c'est vrai un peu
c'est Méditerrané ça c'est pas mauvais
l'h d'olive si un petit peu de gras mais
c'est gras quand même c'est des bons
gras des meilleurs gr d'arachide et il y
a un enjeu parce que par exemple avec la
chaleur extrême qui a eu lieu cette
année en Méditerranée Espagne grisse et
cetera la production a chuté et du CP le
coup de l'huile d'olive a fortement
augmenté c'est un vrai enjeu parce que
les oliviers ce sont des arbres qui ont
une pouss une croissance lente et donc
dans les pays qui sont plus sec la
distance par exemple entre les arbres
elle va être liée à la nappe fréatique
la quantité d'eau disponible et donc ça
fait partie des enjeux aussi importants
d'adaptation pas évidente dans un climat
qui se réchauffe et qui s'assèche en
Méditerranée et puis ça change les
habitudes alimentaires j'étais en
Espagne il y a pas très longtemps les
les Espagnols sont furieux parce que
dans les étal des supermarchés le prix
de l'huile a augmenté et ils savent pas
comment cuisiner et puis en Italie il a
le problème aussi des maladies dans les
Pouilles où on a dû détruire des
centaines de milliers d'oliviers alors
vous vous aimez cuisiner ou pas
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous faites
à la maison des poocher
non non en fait j'ai pas toujours le
temps de cuisiner donc c'est souvent
rapide dans la semaine le soir souvent
c'est une soupe par exemple et puis
après une forme de protéine végétale
varié qu'on va faire et et pu vous allez
choisir moi je mange aussi par exemple
des œufs je mange du fromage des
produits laitiers donc ce qui permet
très facilement en fait voilà c'est ça
exactement pourquoi vous avez décidé de
conserver justement les les laitages et
alors alors vraiment il y a un côté
culturel c'est-à-dire la un des goûts
que j'aime le mieux c'est le goût du
fromage et la diversité de de fromage
qu'on a voilà c'est vraiment le goût en
fait la culture
intensive vous ça vous ça vous exprime
quoi parce que souvent on se dit bon il
faut qu'on puisse nourrir toute la
planète mais en même temps vous nous
disiez il faut du local il faut qu'on
aille chercher à côté de chez soi les
produits alors en fait ce dont on se
rend pas compte c'est que ce qui pèse le
plus sur l'empreinte en terme d'émission
de gaz à effet de serre ou d'utilisation
des terres de l'alimentation c'est pas
la distance du transport le transport
c'est une petite partie le transport par
exemple de marchandis par cargo est
assez efficace donc ce qui pèse le plus
sur les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est ce qu'on mange en fait c'est
pas la distance parcourue mais le le
transport par exemple frigorifié a une
empreinte carbone importante plus que le
reste du coup il y a cette intérêt à à
voilà favoriser ce qui est produit
localement et puis en plus on a des
meilleures qualités nutritives hein
quand on achète directement les légumes
frais qui ont pas été stockés pendant
longtemps le goût est pas du tout le
même alors dites-nous vous par exemple
la banane la la mangue tous ces ces ces
fruits ces légumes qui pourrai être
importés de loin vous n'en mangez jamais
si j'en mange mais j'en mange comme
quelque chose de plus rare et par par
bateau pas par avion parce que le
transport par avion qui se fait he par
exemple pour des ananas des choses comme
ça c'est celui qui a l'empreinte carbone
la plus forte par rapport au kilos de
marchandis si ça vient de par bateau ou
c'est affiché et puis ça se voit dans le
prix aussi en fait mais ce que je
voulais mentionner juste c'est que le
moi je fais aussi partie du Haut Conseil
pour le climat qui regarde plus les
enjeux dans le contexte français euh
donc de de de l'adaptation à un climat
qui change he c'est un enjeu on l'a dit
hein pour le le système alimentaire
aussi de le rendre résilient et et donc
on travaille justement sur un rapport
portant sur agriculture et alimentation
qui va être publié dans quelques
semaines donc je vais pas en dévoiler le
contenu mais ça montre en fait l'ampleur
des enjeux et
donc pour l'utilisation des terres dans
dans son ensemble on est vraiment sur
des défis majeurs d'une part on a une
population qui va augmenter Moné qu'il
faut nourrir on estime un 2 milliards de
personnes en plus à nourrir dans les
décennies qui viennent on a en fait des
chocs sur les rendement agricole lié aux
inondations au plus extrême aux chaleur
extrêmes ou aux sécheresses qui
s'intensifie dans un climat qu'on
réchauffe hein par nos rejet de gaz à
effet de serre on a besoin aussi de
produire de la biomasse par exemple pour
l'énergie ou comme matériaux c'est
compliqué en fait hein pour gérer en
fait l'utilisation des terres et c'est
pour ça qu'en fait l'approche qui est
vraiment importante c'est pas seulement
l'approche production agricole c'est
extrêmement important c'est critique
hein avec des gains possibles sur les
meilleures pratiques l'efficacité
l'action contre les pertes et le
gaspillage mais il y a aussi en fait ce
qu'on choisit de manger les deux en fait
si on ne l'articule pas si ça n'avance
pas ensemble ça fonctionnera pas
imaginons par exemple les pays autour de
nous il y a 10 % de végétariens je crois
c'est l'ordre de grandeur he Suisse
Allemagne royaume-unii en France 2 % de
végétarienard mais si par exemple les
les gens arrêtent de manger de la VI VI
en mange moins ici et qu'on en produit
toujours autant bah ce sera exporté ça
changera rien donc en fait on voit bien
que les les deux aspects ont besoin
d'avancer ensemble et on est sur des
situations très compliquées par exemple
ce qu'on voit c'est que sur par exemple
les Français mangent un peu moins de
viande mais ça reste élevé plus tard ou
et et moins de viande rouge et plus de
poulet et la moitié des poulets sont
importés donc c'est pas du tout
satisfaisant non plus en terme de de
filière agricole alors on a bien compris
que ce plat vous l'aimez beaucoup mais
quand vous avez envie de vous faire
plaisir d'aller dans un restaurant
gastronomique qu'est-ce qui vous fait
kiffer al moi je vais assez rarement
dans des restaurants gastronomiques en
fait pour être honnête c'est c'est
plutôt des des des restaurants qu'on va
trouver moi j'habite en nessonne à 25 km
de Paris il y a pas trop en fait un
d'offre gastronomi c'est des restaurants
type brasserie habituell il y a des
étoilés en campagne dans les zones
rurales on trouve des très bons
restaurant je crois pas que j'ai jamais
été mangé dans un restaurant à plusieurs
étoiles en fait hein mais je fais aussi
partie des gens qui font de la recherche
publique en fait c'est parce que vous
n'y voyez pas d'intérêt de plaisir dans
la nourriture vous contentez de parce
c'est parce que je pense qu'on a dans ma
famille une approche plus sobre en fait
de la partie de notre budget qu'on
consacre à l'alimentation aussi voilà et
la la la brasserie par exemple est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui elle s'est adaptée parce
que en général il y avait pas dans les
brasseries de plats d'offre végétarienne
si il y a toujours et en fait de c'est
un peu toujours les mêmes plats qui sont
proposés alors souvent en fait ce qu'on
voit c'est plutôt une approche un peu
cuisine du monde donc on va avoir des
des des bols en fait un peu typ
asiatique
bas de riz souvent voilà avec des fèves
à base de soja des choses comme ça on va
avoir toute la cuisine méditerranéenne
qui a toujours des choix végétariens
cuisine asiatique aussi en fait par
tradition cuisine indienne aussi voilà
donc c'est plutôt là en fait qu'on va
trouver dans ma famille avec des choix
alimentaires contrastés ce qui convient
à tout le monde vous disiez notre
famille consacre peut-être moins à
l'alimentation enfin ou une part de son
de son revenu aujourd'hui on voit que je
veux dire à la restauration ha de
gammeation l'alimentation générale parce
que si on prend du du bio du local c'est
c'est parfois un petit peu plus cher que
si on va acheter des produits de grande
consommation dans des dans des
supermarchés nous par exemple en estonne
où on est on a aussi la chance sur les
marchés d'avoir des producteurs qui
vendent directement en fait on a aussi
des potagers d'insertion près de chez
nous donc ce sont des personnes qui sont
éloignées de l'emploi en situation
précaire qui sont employé dans ses
potagers qui vendent directement on peut
aller le samedi par exemple et là ça
permet en fait d'avoir un coup abordable
et puis surtout des légumes très frais
délicieux en fait et vous arrivez à
trouver des produits bio abordables ou
c'est il y a quand même quelques
intrants sur ces aspects là oui on peut
trouver des potagers d'insertion bio par
exemple qui font un travail de qualité
hein sur vraiment les légumes qui sont
fournis et puis qui permettent aussi à
des gens de retrouver l'emploi mais
c'est pas la chose la plus facile en
île- defance vos enfants ne vont jamais
dans les fast food et cetera vous avez
réussi à les éduquer moi je peux pas
parler pour mes fills c'est des jeunes
adultes en fait hein mais ah oui mais
quand elles étaient plus jeunes si bien
sûr oui oui il y a il y a une une
pression très forte en fait de la
société à valoriser et compris avec les
petits cadeaux une alimentation qui est
pas forcément le meilleur exemple pour
pour la santé c une bataille avec ces
jeunes il y a eu différentes phases je
pense que comme dans toutes les familles
euh mais mais de filles en fait cuisine
et voilà on une alimentation plus
végétale enfin végétale d'ailleurs
d'accord alors on va voir si vous êtes
vraiment
c'est le
quiz alors vous l'experte en gaz à effet
de serre et en physique des fluides
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sur l'eau gazeuse donc
carbonée sont vraie ou fausses c'est un
horloger allemand du nom de schweep qui
a inventé à Genève en
1873 la première machine à gazéifier
l'eau en fait je n'en ai aucune idée et
bien c'est vrai je vais dire oui voilà
alors je vous ai j'ai bien senti que ce
oui était sincère donc on vous accorde
le point
et ce fameux schweep donnera d'ailleurs
nom le nom de la marque schweeps plus
tard au début du 19e siècle les soda
water comme on dit débarquent sur le
marché mais sont réservé à
l'aristocratie vrai on va dire vrai et
bien non faux parce que c'était une
consommation massive et populaire d'eau
gazéifié parce que ça faisait chic mais
en fait ça dépendait des marques qui
avaient des groses écart de prix entre
des marques lowcost déjà et des marques
aristocratiques mais c'était un
mouvement assez populaire de boire de
l'eau gazïfiée les eau naturellement
gazéifié sont très prisé mais beaucoup
plus cher bien sûr à l'époque à cause
des coûts d'extraction vrai ou
faux je ne sais pas du tout je veis dire
non non c'était surtout l'embouteillage
qui coûtait très cher exactement et
enfin c'est une grande famille anglaise
qui a créé la source d'eau perriée dans
le sud de la France vra vra ou faux
aucune idée je vais dire non mais et
bien non vrai ce sont des Anglais à
perriier per c'est fou mais c'est des
Anglais ce sont des anglais alors vous
allez pouvoir vous rattraper parce qu'il
y a un deè quiz Val vous qui êtes fan de
légumineuse pourriez-vous nous dire
lesquelles sont utilisé dans les
différents potages que je vais vous
donner alors un le poids cassé est-ce
que c'est utilisé dans le condde l' saao
le Saint-Germain ou le
soissonnet alors là c'est une très bonne
question
soissonnet
Saint-Germain je ne pourrais pas vous en
dire plus de le haricot rouge alors
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on l'utilise pour
le Condé les Sao ou le
soissonnet soissonnet alors le con
deuxème tentative le Condé il nous reste
de deux alors je peux ajouter une chose
donc les les poiss cassés délicieux en
purée en soupe les haricots rouges en
fait nous on a une recette de de
substitut de steak qu'on peut faire dans
des burgers à base de betterave mixé et
de haricot rougge d'oignon caramélisé
qui est vraiment délicieuse vraiment
délicieuse en fait une bonne recette et
c'était pour faire diversion dans ou ça
TR on continue hein vous NZ pas vous en
sortir comme ça le haricot blanc est-ce
que c'est dans l'essao ou dans dans le
soissonnet et ben là c'est bon on va
mais oui les haricot de soissonil c'est
ça oui voilà exactement il y avait un
bon finalement le 4 et alors les
lentilles et bien on se retrouve avec
les sa bon ben finalement ça fait quand
m 5050 vous avez quand même deux bonnes
réponses c'est des S traditionnelles ou
des veloutés traditionnelles de
différentes régions exactement c'est r
son à base de légumineuse qui est très
intéressante dans dans les soupes oui
vous le savez sans doute c'est c'est
parfois autour de la table bien que se
raconte les meilleures histoires que ce
nous parfois aussi des deals politiques
que se fait la petite et la grande
histoire c'est la breve de
comptoir Valérie maasson d'mot on vous a
demandé de vous rappeler d'une anecdote
pourquoi pas autour d'un repas en Pol
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
nous raconter oui le mois dernier donc
il y avait le le travail de préparation
du One Planet Summit sur les pôles et
les glaciers donc un sujet important
parce que ce qui se passe dans ces
régions affecte d'autres régions par
exemple l'eau de fonte des glaciers de
la neige qui va alimenter des cours
d'eau donc important par exemple pour
l'irrigation l'agriculture ou bien la
montée du niveau de la mer qui est un
enjeu pour tous les littoraux et
notamment par exemple le risque de
salinisation des eaux côtières ou bien
les grands deltas agricoles au niveau
mondial très exposé à cela et et donc
dans dans ce dîner de préparation il y
avait la ministre de la Recherche le
ministre de la transition écologique il
y avait des membres du conseil
scientifique qui préparait ce ce sommet
euh il y avait Jean-Louis Étienne
également et d'autres personnes et et
donc la discussion elle portait aussi
sur le financement bien sûr euh donc qui
a donné lieu à des annonces du président
de la République à ce sommet et je me
souviens en fait d'une ministre de la
transition écologique qui regardait
finalement le besoin de recherche pour
mieux évaluer les risques d'
d'instabilité de certains secteurs de
l'Antarctique donc c'est le principal
facteur d'incertitude sur l'ampleur et
la montée du niveau de la mer qui peut
rajouter plusieurs dizaines de
centimètres d'ici à la fin du siècle et
il comparait le besoin de de financement
de la recherche française he sur
l'Antarctique au coup ne serait-ce que
de l'évaluation de l'exposition des
communes du littoral c'est infime en
fait ou bien au cout de la du fait de
surélever certaines digues et donc la la
chose intéressante du point de vue
politique c'était se dire on n'arrive
pas à dégager un tout petit budget pour
cette recherche polaire et pourtant les
enjeux économiques sont considérables et
donc c'était le le fait de mettre en
relation ces deux aspectsl oui tout à
fait tout à fait et le montant ça ça
correspond à combien qu'est-ce qu'il
faut l'époque à l'époque ce qui était
discuté c'était un montant de je sais
pas sur sur une dizaine d'années de
l'ordre de 50 millions d'euros pour la
partie financement de la recherche
sachant qu'il y a des investissements
qui ont été actés pour rénover des bases
antarctiques ou avoir un nouveau navir
par exemple donc c'était juste la partie
financement de la recherche à à comparer
au milliards d'euros déjà mis maintenant
pour évaluer en fait l'exposition des
communes françaises au risque de recul
du trait de côte et au montant colossal
he de chaque kilomètre de dig à réhaussé
par exemple ou de la relocalisation qui
devrait être planifiée pour ceux qui
sont en première ligne ça veut dire
aussi qu'avec chaque sous investi dans
la recherche dans l'innovation on peut
aussi faire des économies ensuite non
alors il y a plusieurs aspects mais
notamment ce qu'on sait c'est que tout
ce qui est mis sur la prévention des
risques est toujours extrêmement
efficace par rapport à la réparation
après catastrophe donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement viable et
l'engu en fait c'est donc notamment
parce que le gouvernement français veut
construire une trame de référence pour
l'adaptation donc on voit bien qu'on
peine à réduire suffisamment vite les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde donc sur la base des politiques
publiques actuelles on va vers un
réchauffement dans le monde qui serait
de l'ordre de 3°gr et si toutes les
promesses là faites à horizon 2030 se
réalisent ce serait entre 2,5i et 3°gr
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire en France
4 degrés en fin de siècle en France 3
degr en 2050 ça veut dire que en 2050 ce
qui était l'année la plus chaude
enregistrée à ce jour 2022 avec son
cortège en fait d'impacte grave alors
maintenant on sait que c'est l'année
2023 alors la plus chaude et 2022 2023
est juste derrière ah bon j'ai cru que
c'était en France en France en France ah
oui pas dans le monde en France ça veut
dire que cette année-là 2022 vague de
chaleur sécheresse feu touret vous vous
souvenez hein h la plus chaude
enregistrée serait l'année moyenne en
2050 donc l'enjeu c'est se préparer à ce
que sera l'année record de 2050 pour
renforcer la résilience pour l'eau pour
la production alimentaire les
infrastructures clés les les endroits où
on vit et tout le reste et donc voilà
donc investir pour mieux caractériser la
réponse de l'Antarctique c'est aussi
savoir quel sera le rythme l'ampleur de
la montée du niveau de la mer et c'est
pas la même chose si ça monte de 1 m en
2300 ou si ça monte de 1 m avant 2100
pour beaucoup de communes du littoral
donc cette information là elle est
importante
s les meuratégies de répse vous nous
parlez de 2022 de cette canicule juste
après le président de la République vous
a demandé de venir vous exprimer devant
l'ensemble du gouvernement je ne sais
pas si c'était au tour du du repas
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
c'était très formel c'était dans le
cadre d'un séminaire de rentrée
gouvernementale donc dans une salle
assez spectaculaire de l'Élysée avec
tous les ministres et secrétaires d'État
et donc moi j'étais là au titre de
l'état des lieux scientifiques en fait
hein monde et France sur les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre dans le contexte
où la première ministre a mis en place
tout un aspect de planification
écologique qui commence en fait he à se
décliner
graduellement sachant que il y a ce
double enjeu finalement c'est comment on
fait face à un climat qui se réchauffe
pour être résilient et après d'autre
part c'est comment on fait pour limiter
l'ampleur du réchauffement parce qu'on
est devant des choses qui vont être très
dures à gérer en fait hein notamment
dans les tous les contexte plus fragile
je pensais à ça en écoutant les
personnes qui ont été touchées par les
inondations dans le nord de la la France
et qui disait voilà nous on est coincé
là en fait on est en zone inondable
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire pour
limiter le risque quelle est la valeur
de nos biens on voit bien qu'on est dans
le dur maintenant en fait hein c'est pas
et sur quoi s'interrogaient les les
politiques par exemple donc il y a eu il
y a eu moi j'ai présenté l'état des
lieux en en 20 une vingtaine une
trentaine de minutes puis après j'ai
écouté leurs échanges et un des points
qui était assez frappant c'est un des
ministres qui a dit donc d'abord ils
étaient pour beaucoup d'entre eux en
plein dedans ils avaient géré crise
après-crise tout l'été donc ils étaient
vraiment bien concerné mais la question
qui a était posée c'est on comprend bien
qu'on va devoir enclencher des
changements structurels et chaque fois
qu'on on met en place des changements
structurels bah certains le comprennent
et d'autres le comprennent moins donc
quel est le capital politique qu'on peut
gagner à ça et après j'ai écouté leurs
échang un intérêt politique j'ai écouté
leurs échanges qui sont instructifs
parce que c'est pas mon monde en fait
hein moi je suis dans un monde de
physicienne voilà mais c'est c'est
instructif à à à noter comme tous les
enjeux en fait d'articulation de mise en
cohérence de politique publique que j'ai
découvert via le conseil pour le climat
et souvent les scientifiques raillaient
les hommes politiques parce qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas bien toutes ces
questions vous trouvez que ça a changé
un peu maintenant ils sont plus
technique plus experts il y a vraiment
un enjeu de monter en compétence et ce
qu'on voit c'est que d'abord il y a
besoin toujours hein de de formation de
formation continue sur l'état des
connaissances sur ces enjeux-là euh il y
en a qui se les sont approprier mais pas
tous euh donc il y a eu des actions
justement de formation notamment de
cabinet ministériel de l'administration
publique ça c'est extrêmement important
h et après il y a au-delà de simplement
une sensibilisation c'est comment on
porte ces transformations qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne quel est le retour
d'expérience d'autres pays quelles sont
les meilleures pratiques ça c'est des
compétences de conduite du changement en
fait de science politique et on voit
bien qu'il y a ce ce besoin et pour moi
c'est vraiment une des valeurs des COP
elles sont souvent critiqué les
négociations internationales sur le
climat mais finalement c'est un espace
de dialogue où on va avoir des
coalitions d'une ambition forte dans tel
ou tel sujet par exemple agriculture
alimentation c'est ressorti là du bail
plus fort qu'avant et d'autre part c'est
là où il y a les des retours
d'expérience des meilleures pratiques de
ce qui fonctionne qui sont qui peuvent
être inspirants qui peuvent être
vraiment engageants on va continuer
évidemment à parler à parler de tout ça
et on va d'abord s'intéresser à l'impact
de la viande sur la planète qu'est-ce
qui se cache derrière un steak ou une
côte de veau et bien c'est le dessous
des
plats la production et la consommation
de viande ont un impact important sur le
réchauffement climatique l'élevage
serait responsable de 14,5 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
pourquoi la Cour des comptes préconise
de réduire le cheptel à les écouter les
Français y sont prêts reportage Clément
perouau et elzar
logonitech les Français réduisent-ils
leur consommation de viande au marché de
malakov en banlieu parisienne la réponse
est plutôt oui les consommateurs se
veulent de plus en plus responsable si
on mange moins de viand
dans l'EM ça devrait contribuer à un
meilleur meilleur climat MOS d'énergie
dépensée et C consommer trop de viande
c'est éventuellement aussi pollué
peut-être et en plus pour la santé je
pense que il est nécessaire de de
réduire notre consommation j'achète des
des produits plus respectueux de la
façon dont on traite les animaux par
rapport oui quand même à la nature on en
mange beaucoup moins qu'avant nos
parents prenai beaucoup plus de viande à
une époque que nous aujourd'hui les
dernières enquêtes d'opinion sont
claires les Français sont de plus en
plus nombreux à déclarer consommer moins
de viande 57 % selon une étude Haris
interactive réalisée cette année
pourtant cette tendance ne se vérifie
pas vraiment dans les
chiffres en 1998 les Français
consommaient 93,6 kg de viande par an en
moyenne ensuite une baisse significative
s'est amorcé jus jusqu'en 2013 mais
depuis 10 ans la consommation repart en
légère hausse à l'échelle mondiale
l'évolution est beaucoup plus nette la
production globale de viande est en
constante augmentation depuis les années
60 la progression la plus forte est en
Asie 43 % de la production mondiale y
est désormais concentré principalement
pour le PC et la volaille l'Afrique est
aujourd'hui le continent qui consomme le
moins de viande mais un bon de 200 % est
prévu d'ici
2050 toutes ces évolutions sont
observées de près par les organismes qui
travaillent sur le réchauffement
climatique l'enjeu est majeur 14,5 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
proviennent aujourd'hui de
l'élevage ce qui pèse le plus c'est la
production des aliments pour nourrir le
bétail viennent ensuite les
fermentations anentériques les rau des
animaux qui produisent beaucoup de
méthane le fumier pèse aussi dans
l'équation tout comme l'énergie
consommée notamment par le
transport les les émissions dépendent
aussi des espèces la viande la plus
émérice et le bœuf en produire 1 kil
entraîent 38 kg de CO2 viennent ensuite
l'agneau le porc et le
poulet alors Valérie maçonmot peut-on
vraiment sauver la planète en réduisant
mondialement la consommation de
viande à vous de répondre alors Val
oui en fait faire évoluer l'éducation en
fait une alimentation saine et durable
finalement sur voilà une consommation
responsable de viande de produits
laitiers ça peut faire partie des
leviers d'action mais ça veut dire quoi
une consommation responsable pour vous
en quelle quantité faudrait-il réduire
sa consommation de viande alors ça
dépend en fait de point de départ parce
qu'en fait selon les personnes on a des
pratiques avec des consommations qui
peuvent être très élevées ou tout à fait
raisonnablesp par semaine est-ce que
c'est de la viande un jour sur deux
est-ce que l'idée en fait c'est pas
n'importe VI en plus ça dépend de la
viande non l'idée en fait donc si on
regarde en France sur l'emprinte carbone
donc les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par personne et par an à peu près
9 tonnes le premier poste c'est les
transports le deuxième poste c'est
effectivement l'alimentation avec la
partie on va dire protéine animale qui
pèse plus que le reste puis après la
partie boisson parce que c'est lourd en
fait hein c'est le transport plus de de
plus loin de de choses plus lourdes et
et donc on voit que si on regarde par
exemple les recommandations
nutritionnelles on peut tout à fait
vivre très bien en mangeant un deux
steaks par exemple par semaine quand on
en mangeait davantage mais on n'est pas
nécessairement obligé de le faire
protéin voilà on n'est pas obligé de le
faire et c'est ce côté-là qui est
intéressant c'est que il y a pas une
réponse univoque il y a une multitude de
choix ce qu'on voit également c'est que
les personnes avec des niveaux de
revenus plus élevés réduisent leur
consommation de viande pour leur santé
en fait et oui mais ce qu'on voit aussi
c'est qu'effectivement les pays en voie
de développement enfin qui vont pouvoir
permettre d'accéder à la viande vont en
consommer 200% plus parce qu'en fait
historiquement ça a augmenté avec les
revenus en fait simplement la capacité à
pouvoir acheter davantage de viande qui
est plus
cher voilà mais ça c'est culturel et
donc comment on peut aussi faire évoluer
notre regard sur ça pour se dire voilà
culturellement qu'est-ce qu'on va le
plus valoriser et on voit bien par
exemple en France hein dans les les
personnes qui ont les revenus les plus
contraints il y a une aspiration à
consommer de la viande comme un signe de
pouvoir nourrir sa famille avec voilà
des protéines qu'on associe à des valeur
en fait de force par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'on dit par exemple à l'Afrique qui
elle va consommer c'est prévu beaucoup
plus de viande d'ici 2050 200 % de plus
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit eux
ils ont envie d'accéder à la viande il
n'y avait pas n'avait pas de pouvoir
d'achat pour le faire avant on leur dit
B non vous alors moi ce qui m'a frappé
rédire il faut même pas commencer en
2019 nous on avait porté un rapport du
GX spécial sur le changement climatique
l'utilisation des terres en la sécurité
alimentaire c'est un enjeu considérable
he aujourd'hui et notamment en Afrique
c'est enjeu de sécurité alimentaire avec
des scientifiques du monde entier
c'était un des rapports je trouais qui
était le plus constructif parce que ça
montrait quelles étaient les les options
d'action euh qui permettent à la fois de
de répondre à des enjeux d'adaptation à
un climat qui se réchauffe de réduction
d'émissions de préservation des
écosystèmes de la biodiversité hein
parce que si on on veut davantage
nourrir un cheptel d'animaux important
dans le monde on va déforester pour
avoir des espaces de culture par exemple
mais on pourrait imaginer aussi et donc
là ce qui était frappant c'est que donc
il y a des contextes euh où les gens
dépendent vraiment euh notamment dans
des zones semi-arides euh des protéines
animales et c'est critique en fait hein
euh pour leur sécurité alimentaire il y
a d'autres contextes où il y a d'autres
alternatives possibles il y a des
traditions il y a des pratiques et donc
ce qui ressortait notamment des
scientifique africain c'est un un un
chercheur d'ailleurs euh du Sénégal qui
avait piloté le chapitre qui portait sur
l'alimentation c'était aussi de
valoriser euh euh le les connaissances
euh locales euh culturelles sur une
alimentation saine et sous soutenable
parce qu'en fait le le fait de de
consommer davantage de viande ne vient
pas forcément spontanément des
populations locales c'est aussi quelque
chose qui est construit par des acteurs
industriels et sur ce rapport et les
autres du GC quand on avait souligné les
enjeux bien sûr de soutien aux
agriculteur pour qu'il soit résilient
pour que les meilleures pratiques type
polilyculture élevage en fait soit
valorisé l'élevage sur herbe c'est une
des meilleures options par exemple pour
réduire l'empreinte
carbone des ruminants et des produits
laitiers donc on a aussi a des
savoir-faire c'est important de les
valoriser euh ce qui ce qui ressortait
assez nettement c'était plutôt les
grands pays exportateurs de viande
notamment en Amérique du Sud qui
eux-mêmes ont essayé d'affaiblir la
partie qui portait sur le fait de
végétaliser l'alimentation c'est pas il
y avait pas d'obstruction de pays
africains ou autres comme le Brésil par
exemple Brésil Argentine et donc là
vraiment c'est plutôt je dirais
l'industrie de l'exportation de viande à
très grande échelle qui cherche à
conserver ses marchés ou à créer de
nouveau marchés c'est pas forcément des
aspirations spontanées et locales donc
c'est je pense à regarder avec
précaution les deux sujets les plus
sensibles dans l'approbation des
rapports du Gex c'était celui-là donc
végétaliser la la part des protéines
quand on quand on en consomme trop
réduire les protéines animal et le
deuxième sujet le plus sensible c'est
celui qui portait sur le fait de réduire
l'utilisation d'énergie fossile c'était
pas les mêmes acteurs hein là c'était
plutôt les exportateurs d'énergie
fossile est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
que les animaux mangent une autre
nourriture c'estàd pas le soja
qui oblige à déforester une partie de de
l'Amazonie bah de l'herbe par exemple
pour les ruminants c'est ce qui fait
mieuxou de l'herbe dans l'Afrique
subsarienne aussi aux émissions de gaz à
effet de ser c'est toute la nourriture
pour les pour les animaux oui bien sûr
et est-ce qu'on voit également enfin
dans le reportage tout à l'heure c'était
assez marqué les gens ont l'impression
de consommer moins de viande mais
notamment avec tous les plats préparés
les fast food il y a une tendance en
fait dans l'alimentation on va dire plus
industrielle facile à accéder à avoir
une consomm tion plus élevé de de viande
du coup on est sur des choses un peu
contradictoires il y a aussi des effets
liés à l'âge où souvent c'est les
personnes plus âgées qui veulent faire
attention à leur santé et donc font
évoluer leur alimentation la végétalise
un peu plus par contre il y a parfois
une forme d'indifférence chez les plus
jeunes aussi scénario pardon scénario
fiction Brigitte on interdit la viande
on sauve la planète ou pas je pense que
ça se pose pas du tout dans ces termesl
ni en France ni partout ailleurs dans le
monde c'est plutôt en fait alors
pourquoi je vais l'expliquer donc le
reportage tout tout à l'heure reliait je
sais pas c Ctait 1 kil de de différents
types de viande à des émissions de CO2
mais c'est pas ça qui fonctionne c'est
pas ça fonctionne pas comme ça ce sont
des émission de méthane et par les
épendages d'oxyde nitreux deux autres
gaz à effet de serre pour arriver à
limiter le réchauffement il va être
critique d'arriver à des émissions de
CO2 à 0 net ça c'est la première chose
donc ça c'est essentiellement énergie
fossile déforestation et pour le méthane
il s'agit de réduire il s'agit pas
d'aller à zéro donc il faut pas non plus
avoir une vision qui soit caricaturale
donc on peut continuer à manger de la
viande en fait voilà mais en valorisant
les filières les plus vertueuses donc
par exemple les ruminants sur herbes
donc c'est aussi une viande qui va être
plus cher donc l'idée c'est dans dans la
réflexion c'est valoriser les meilleures
pratiques comment les rendre mieux
visibles comment reconnaître les efforts
qui sont faits par notamment les
exploitants qui mettent en place les
meilleures
pratiques et puis c'est un enjeu sur les
marchés internationaux donc on parlait
tout à l'heure hein de de l'alimentation
industrielle là en fait les les les les
commerçants enfin la grande distribution
va aller chercher la viande la moins
chère faite dans les conditions qui sont
pas exactement ce qu'on décrivait tout à
l'heure mais ça ne se voit pas pour le
consommateur donc comment arriver aussi
à le rendre plus visible et pour
rebondir sur la question de Brigitte qui
parlait de l'alimentation est-ce qu'on
peut pas changer le on j'ai entendu dire
qu'on pouvait il fallait la changer pour
baisser les les émissions de méthane il
fallait peut-être transformer la
nourriture des
animaux a il y a des enjeux sur les les
pratiques d'alimentation certains
compléments alimentaires qui peuvent
permettre effectivement de réduire un
peu cet aspect là donc c'est des petits
leviers d'action mais qui sont pas du
tout négligeables à grande échelle ça
fait partie des choses hein qui sont
explorées actuellement la viande de
synthèse par exemple ça peut être une
solution pour palier finalement ce euh
ce ceutêtre ches de VI traditionnel moi
je pense c'est plutôt des choses un peu
de niche parce que bien sûr sur si on
veut brasser en fait des cellules
animales ça revient à ça un peu comme on
brasse de la bière en fait hein bah il y
a une consommation de de de matières
premièr pour le faire d'énergie et donc
voilà il faut bien regarder euh ce qu'on
gagne ce qu'on ce qu'on évite il me
semble que ceux qui favorisent ces
approches là sont plutôt ceux qui ont un
attachement à éviter la souffrance
animal notamment et et donc il serait
intéressé à avoir des alternatives sans
sans cette dimensionl donc il y a
quelques démonstrateurs mais c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
aujourd'hui à l'échelle nécessaire et
puis souvent associé à un coût assez
élevé et les insectes alors dans
beaucoup de régions du monde en fait les
insectes sont une source de protéin oujà
oui mais est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut
pas la FAO veut mettre le paquet sur les
insectes tiel pour l'alimentation des
animaux d'élevage notamment à partir de
protéines issu d'insectes avec une
empreinte plus soutenable en fait voilà
donc ça peut faire partie des lev d'
voilà mais il y a des freins culturels
qui sont intéressants là quand on parle
de des pratiques alimentaires on voit
bien que c'est encré dans des cultures
donc en France c'est tout à fait
acceptable par exemple de manger des
cuisses de grenouilles dans d'autres
pays du monde pas du tout et après ça
demande à regarder par exemple sur les
cuisses de grenouilles qui sont importé
de pays où on a une chute en fait de la
diversité de batracien typiquement en
Indonésie on est vraiment sur des choses
pas du tout durables il y a un décalage
entre le ressenti des gens et puis la
réalité des filières d'approvisionnement
et et c'est pour ça en fait les insectes
ou d'autres choses dans certaines
régions du monde voilà c'est perçu comme
une chance comme quelque chose qui est
associé parfois à des fêtes des moments
dans les saisons et donc ça ça demande
aussi de voilà s'interroger sur le
regard qu'on porte sur différentes
sources de protéines alors en plus
d'émettre beaucoup de gaz à effet de ser
et bien la culture est le secteur le
plus gros consommateur d'eau l'eau une
denrée de plus en plus rare avec le
réchauffement climatique on en parle et
on met les pieds dans le
plin bien figurez-vous qu'avec la
sécheresse une source c'est Taris dans
le département de l'AUE résultat deux
petits villages au régime sec au robinet
l'eau qui coule provient de camion citne
pas de pluie non plus dans les champs
pour irriguer les cultures toute une vie
au quotidien est à réinventer pour les
200 habitants c'est un reportage de
Clément
perouau la sécheresse au mois de
décembre Coustouge dans le massif des
Corbières affronte une pénurie d'eau
pour y remédier voilà le traitement des
camions citernes viennent alimenter le
village deux fois par semaine l'eau
vient de lésignan à 25 km
d'ici il y a 29000 l là et ça tient à
peu près 2 jours sur la commune l'eau
est versée dans le réseau communal de
Coustouge et de Jonquier le village
voisin les deux communes rassemblent 200
habitants au total leurs mères sont venu
tous les deux assister aux opération la
situation les inquiète beaucoup on ne
contrôle plus rien on est tributaire des
des
précipitations et les prévisions météo
sont très très défavorables on parle
souvent d'un dérèglement climatique et
cetera et on on est en plein dedans on
est en plein dedans on est un manque
crucial de précipitation ces deux
dernières années et voilà à quoi ça
abouti une pénurie d'eau pour nos deux
villages et ce fameux ravitaillement par
citerne depuis plusieurs années les deux
villages étaient alimenté par cette
source mais elle s'est définitivement
tarie fin novembre faute de
précipitation c'est sec c'est inédit on
l'a jamais vu vraiment asséché à ce
point généralement ça coule toujours un
petit peu et là on a plus rien du tout
dans ces conditions au village les
habitants ont appris à limiter leur
consommation d'eau chacun à sa manière
on a mis économiseurs d'eau au à chaque
robinet pour la douche on met moins de
temps pour se laver pour les chass on
économise la vaisselle ou de la faire
systématiquement je la fais le matin
voilà et je stock la vaisselle des
choses comme ça voilà la pénu rideau
n'affecte pas que le quotidien des
particuliers conjugué aux fortes chaleur
elle est une calamité pour les
viticulteurs comme Valérie segon sa
vigne est en situation de stress
hydrique là on a de la repousse la la
feuille la vigne repousse alors qu'on
est au mois de décembre la vigne est
complètement déréglée sait pas qu'on est
au mois de décembre pour schématiser là
elle s'apprête à pousser alors que c'est
en mars avril qu'elle pousse elle se
croit au printemps elle se croit au
printemps le bois des vignes est aussi
beaucoup plus faible cette année sur sur
cette parcelle la production de vin a
chuté de 60
%. alors alimenter un visage un village
de 200 habitants et des camions citernes
ça va mais si jamais dans les années qui
viennent dans les décennies ce sont des
villes entières de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'habitants comment va-t-on
faire Valérie maçon Delmon oui et là on
voit en fait les enjeux majeurs liés au
réchauffement planétaire où en fait à
mesure de l'ampleur du réchauffement
dans certaines régions c'est une baisse
de la pluviométrie qui va aggraver en
fait hein occurrence l'intensité des
sécheresses c'est le cas cette année en
Amazonie par exemple ça a été le cas en
France en 2022 sécheresse record encore
maintenant sur la partie Espagne aussi
les sécheresses oui puis là actuellement
sur la partie vraiment méditerranéenne
on l'a vu tout à l'heure ça veut dire
quoi qu'il va y avoir des camions citern
qui vont se promener comme ça dans
plusieurs villes de France pour pour
alimenter en eau je pense je pense aussi
dans l'actualité à la nouvelle-orléand
où il y a une entrée d'eau salée qui
fait que l'alimentation en eau potable
est compliquée parce que l'eau devient
de plus en plus saline donc impropre à
la la consommation Mayotte en fait plus
d'eau potable reportage il livre des
millions de bouteilles donc là on est
sur une autre échelle qui pose la
question sur les petites îles qui n'ont
pas de stock d'une plus grande
vulnérabilité et puis les déchets aussi
hein qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le
plastique de ces bouteilles
catastrophiques et catastrophique pour
la vie au quotidien donc on voit en fait
que dans un climat qui se réchauffe en
fait on a un cycle de l'eau plus intense
et plus variable plus de saisons et
d'événements très humides et très secs
donc parfois c'est l'excès et parfois
c'est la pénurie en région miterranéenne
c'est vraiment dans les points chauds
d'un climat qui se réchauffe parce qu'en
fait on a une tendance à avoir moins de
précipitation et puis quand il fait plus
chaud on vide plus rapidement les sol de
leur humidité en plus donc il y a le les
deux facteurs qui jouent dans le même
sens qu a un excès d'eau on se rend
compte que les NAP pratiques remontent
pas forcément d'un coup alors ça va
dépendre en fait il y a l'effet surface
puis après il y a le temps de réponse
des nappes avec parfois l'utilisation
locale des nappes qui est pas du tout
senable c'està-dire on prélève beaucoup
plus d'eau que ce qui se renouvelle
régulièrement donc le niveau des nappes
baisse comme en Espagne par exemple et
là on est sur des enjeux d'aridification
et moi ce qui me frappe également c'est
dans les conflits récents à quel point
l'eau est une arme de guerre et l'eau
est un facteur de conflit par exemple
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie il y a une
utilisation non durable de l'eau dans la
partie Est de l'Ukraine et l'eau a été
utilisé dans les deux cas comme une arme
de guerre entre Israël et Palestine on
est sur pareil contexte méditerranéen
une ressource très contrainte y compris
un appauvrissement des nappes et une
population qui augmente donc on est sur
des des des des tensions qui sont très
lourdes des alternatives est-ce que je
pense en France notamment le traitement
des os usés la désalinisation est-ce que
ça ça peut être des alternatives ou ou
pas alors ça fait partie des choses
qu'on a regardé dans un rapport de
l'Académie des technologies sur comment
est-ce qu'on peut finalement rajouter
des ressources en eau qui étaient pas
exploité précédemment donc il y a un
potentiel très limité sur la
désalinisation ça consomme beaucoup
d'énergie donc très restreint à certains
contextes spécifiques type î par exemple
et puis on rejette le S du coup l'eau
est encore plus salée c'est ça donc il y
a des enjeux de le faire le moins mal
possible quand on le fait après donc
pourant sur le papier c'est assez on
c'est une très bne solution ça consomme
beaucoup d'énergiep d' ensuite la
deuxième chose sur réutiliser des EAU
usé donc dans certains context c'est
tout à fait faisable mais c'est des
enjeux aussi d'assurer la qualité de ces
EOS donc par rapport à leurs usages un
cadre qui est l'Austral pratiquement 90
% deand moyen d'avoir une véritable
alternative exactement mais c'est pas ça
qui va augmenter la ressource donc en
France on s'attend à mesure du
réchauffement à avoir donc une
augmentation des vagues de chaleur une
baisse de l'humidité des sols graduell
et donc ce qu'on voit c'est une double
contrainte on aura besoin de plus d'eau
par exemple pour l'irrigation pour
garder les mêmes cultures en fait et
d'autre part on aura une ressource qui
risque de diminuer et elle diminue aussi
parce que dans un climat plus chaud on a
l'enneigement qui se réduit on a un peu
de recul des glaciers aussi et donc le
la la capacité à déstocker de l'eau euh
quand on a le plus besoin se réduit
également depuis les régions de haute
montagne donc la la la réponse n'est pas
seulement dans les technologies qui vont
permettre d'utiliser mieux l'eau c'est
aussi en fait ce qui était tout à fait
décrit par les habitants du village ce
qu'on peut faire dans nos pratiques au
quotidien c'est le système D en fait il
faut c'est être plus efficace aussi à
l'échelle individuelle collecou moins
longu par exemple peut-être pas tirer la
chasse d'IG à chaque fois économiser
finalement quand on fait la vaisselle
c'est c'est c'est tout ça oui mais ça
c'est l'échelle individuelle après on a
toute la qualité des réseaux d'eau qui
du quotidien c'est efficace ou pas c'est
une partie de la réponse mais il y a
aussi tous les réseaux d'eau qui peuvent
fuir donc là les entretenir c'est un
point très important la qualité des
réseaux et puis ensuite ce qui prélève
le plus d'eau notamment en été c'est
bien sûr l'irrigation donc avoir aussi
des techniques très performantes de
microirrigation par exemple qui vont
permettre d'assurer la sécurité
alimentaire he c'est un point important
tout en limitant l'utilisation de la
rour on entend que sobriété sobriété euh
finalement c'est une politique publique
moi dir c'est plutôt c'est plutôt en
fait une approche vraiment intelligente
euh c'est pas forcément sobriété parce
qu'en fait on est surtout sur des
situations de gaspillage en fait souvent
donc c'est plutôt en fait être le plus
intelligent collectivement sur ce qui
peut être fait et il y a des exemples
dans plein de pays différents justement
qui montrent ce qui peut être fait mais
aussi parfois les limites dures c'est un
terme qu'on utilise par rapport à
l'adaptation au changement climatique
dans certains cas B on a un peu le dos
au mur quand on n' pas d'eau dans un
cours d'eau c'est une limite dure quand
on a une source qui se tarie c'est une
limite dure où là on voit bien que on va
passer en gestion de crise et pas en
résilience en fait hein alors une douche
courte c'est le bon sens est-ce que on a
déjà réglementé l'usage de l'eau dans
les cultures est-ce que un jour on a on
va pas être obligé de réglementer
l'usage à l'intérieur des maisons ça
vous le voyez ça venir alors il y a des
réflexions par exemple sur les besoins
de base et la tarification par exemple
pour les besoins de base avoir un
tarif et puis au contraire augmenter
quand on a une utilisation excessive par
rapport à la taille de la oui mais ça
c'est pour gonfler la facture et pour
limiter les gens mais réglementer
vraiment l'usage de l'eau quand on vous
entend tout à l'heure oui quand on vous
entend les scén moi j'ai jamais entendu
parler de de la moindre réflexion dans
ce sens et ce qu'on voit dans les
communes qui sont touchées par des
restriction très dur c'est que les gens
très vite prennent la mesure des enjeux
et se partagent les meilleures pratiques
aussi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui mais quand
on a entendu tout à l'heure votre exposé
on se dit dans dans 30 ans à mon avis on
nous dira vous avez droit à 5 litres par
jour aujourd'huiul exemple le seul
exemple que j'ai vu en ce bah ça c'est
ce qu' a à Mayotte hein bah alors voilà
c'est ce qui a à Mayotte hein et c'est
atroce en fait hein euh enfin vous
imaginez la vie
al j'ai vu par exemple à Singapour où en
fait ils sont très contraints sur
l'utilisation de l'eau ils rachètent les
eaux usées de la Malaisie il les
traitent pour l'approvisionnement de
Singapour he qui a très peu de
ressources et ce qui était plutôt
c'était de de de l'encouragement donc
par exemple dans les douches une couleur
qui passe de je sais plus mettons du
vert au bleu au bout de quelques minutes
qui donne un signal c'est pas du tout
une obligation mais c'est un signal
voilà maintenant maintenant c'est du
luxe vous avez déjà utilisé voilà et et
c'est plutôt C ces approches incitatives
le bon sens le fait de se prendre en
main en fait collectivement quand on est
dans des situations de tension qui
fonctionnent le mieux Valérie maçon
delmot il y a la COP 28 qui a lieu en ce
moment à à Dubaï quelles sont les
décisions qu'il faudrait prendre selon
vous pour limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,52°gr qui était l'accord
de Paris alors ce qu'on voit c'est que
le premier facteur du réchauffement
actuel et futur c'est le cumul des
émissions de dioxyde de carbone qu'on
émet quand on brûle du charbon du
pétrole du gaz ou lorsqu'on on détruit
une forêt et euh donc la marge de
manœuvre pour limiter le réchauffement à
1 degr5i en fait année après année elle
elle se réduit on estime maintenant que
au rythme actuel d'émission parce que ça
continue encore à monter légèrement
moins vite qu'avant euh on aura épuisé
la marge de manœuvre qui nous reste pour
contenir le réchauffement à 1 degré et
demi avant la fin de cette décennie donc
on va vers ce niveau-là de réchauffement
ça va être compliqué ça va demander plus
d'effort d'adaptation plus d'effort pour
accompagner les plus fragiles notamment
les mécanismes liés aux pertes et
dommages et donc le point clé c'est si
on veut être sérieux euh arriver à
limiter le réchauffement le plus près
possible de ce niveau-là pour éviter des
choses ingérables hein dont on a parlé
pour l'eau la sécurité alimentaire c'est
en fait planifier collectivement une
sortie des énergies fossiles de toutes
les énergies fossiles c'est planifier
une sortie graduelle des énergies
fossiles en commençant bien sûr par le
char le charbon donc là Emmanuel Macron
a fixé 2030 comme objectif a en France
mais aussi 2027 en France et 2030 pour
tout le monde c'est app c'est app mais
les ind veent pas les Chinois pétrole
puis gaz donc ça c'est vraiment
important et on voitou à quelle échéance
le graduel et à horizon 2050 si on veut
vraiment avoir réussi à limiter le
réchauffement il faudrait que les
émissions mondial de CO2 du aux
activités humaines seul hein soit à zéro
c'est-à-dire si jamais on en émet encore
dans des secteurs très difficiles on
soit capable d'en éliminer et on y est
pas euh et dans ce contexte là chaque
mot compte donc on voit bien là qu' on
est dans le dur au moment de la COP 28
où cette question elle est sur le devant
de la table c'est une COP présidée par
le PDG de la compagnie national émirati
dans un pays euh qui euh voilà est un
exportateur de gaz et de pétrole comme
beaucoup dans cette région euh un pays
qui aborde plus frontalement les enjeux
de diversification économique que
d'autres pays de la même région et
notamment l'Arabie Saoudite là qui a
pris des positions très dures euh ne
souhaitant pas qu'on mentionne le fait
de sortir des énergies fossiles même
l'utilisation de ces termes donc vous
avez un doute sur la réussite de cette
COP non non on est dans le dur et ça il
faut bien le comprendre et moi j'ai vu
notamment dans des rapports d'évaluation
scientifique comme ceux du GC euh le
poids très fort de pays exportateur
d'énergie fossile l'Arabie Saoudite la
Russie et d'autres pour essayer
d'atténuer les conclusions pour servir
leurs intérêts notamment par exemple de
dire l'enjeu c'est pas de sortir des
énergies fossiles pour eux c'est de
réduire les émissions en faisant miroité
une capacité d'arriver à utiliser des
énergies fossiles en captant les
émissions de CO2 et en les stockant et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le Haut
Conseil pour le climat a rendu un avis
sur cet aspect-l donc avant la COP hein
la semaine dernière à la demande de la
première ministre pour évaluer le
potentiel réel et c'est faut quand même
bien comprendre que les compagnies
pétrolières ce qu'elles savent faire
c'est transporter du liquide et du gaz
et le stocker ou le déstocker de
réservoir géologiqu donc dans leur
vision des choses après avoir été payé
pour en extraire être payé pour le
capter et le stocker c'est peut-être une
opportunité mais le potentiel est limité
le coût est élevé ça ne se déploie pas
du tout à l'échelle donc l'enjeu c'est
monter très vite en puissance sur
l'efficacité énergétique les
renouvelables le nucléaire pour ceux qui
souhaitent le faire ça a fait partie des
annonces en début de Cop et là on est
dans le dur parce qu'il s'agit pas de
rajouter des énergies renouvelables en
plus du donc on espère en tout cas qu'il
y aura une une décision qui ira dans le
bon sens et qui sera prise à cette COP
28 on va passer maintenant au dessert
puisque tout le monde a fini et c'est p
c'est
mignon alors après les légumes de saison
et bien on est un peu dans la logique on
a droit à des fruits de saison enfin
c'est ce qu'avait demandé madame maçon
d'elmotte alors je vois que dans cette
salade de fruits il y a des fruits qui
sont certes de saison mais pas forcément
de chez nous vous nous direz si c'est
une bonne chose en tous les cas la
sobriété les fruits de saison les
légumes de saison c'est un peu votre
mantra on s'attendait un peu une
pâtisserie un truc un peu rock and roll
mais non rien alors en fait faut que
j'explique que j'ai eu un rhume carabiné
comme beaucoup de monde en fait hein la
semaine dernière et du coup on a besoin
de vitamine aussi d'accord sinon on aura
droit à une MSE au chocolat non vous
vous êtes plutôt fruits que que que
dessert que pâtisserie non non j'aime
bien en fait aussi le sucré de manière
raisonnable un de mes desserts préférés
en fait c'est le clafouti au ceris par
exemple vraiment que je trouve délicieux
mais c'est pas la saison c'est pas la
saison oui bien sûr oui oui oui c'est de
la pâte à crêpe avec des cerises c'est
très facile oui ça c'est vrai que c'est
assez bon alors vous savez on finit
toujours cette émission en chanson en
musique vous avez choisi celle-là on va
l'écouter
ensemble cher Fabien tu ne me connais
pas encore je suis ton Petitfils je
t'écris depuis l'année 2083 je te passe
ce message afin que ton époque réagisse
ici la planète va mal il faut absolument
que tu me crois Jakarta Lagos New York
ont disparu sous la mer mais aussi
Venise Londres et un/ers des Pays-Bas
tombouou et le nord Mali enseveli sous
le désert et le fleuve Niger n'a plus
une seule goutte d'eau dans ses bras les
villes côtières qui lutte contre la
montée des EAU ont beau construire des
Diges des barrages et des murailles
elles ne pèsent pas bien lourd et éclate
vite en morceau quand les cyclones et
ouragans viennent finir le travail dans
plusieurs pays d'Afrique et d'Asie du
sud-est mais aussi à athèn au Ker et
quelques autres élus il fait souvent
60°gr chaque été est un test où les
riches vivent sous la clime et les
pauvres ne vivent
plus alors c'est 2083 de Grand Corps
Malade on a compris le message
écologique et politique en fait c'est
une chanson où il fait parler son
Petitfils si j'ai bien compris en 2083
avec lui fait une petite référence au
fait d'ignorer les rapports du G
actuellement et j'aime bien ce côté se
projeter c'est-à-dire se dire voilà où
on sera à ce moment-là comment on vivra
qu'est-ce qu'on fera quels sont les
futurs qu'on a pas envie de vivre où
est-ce qu'on veut être et comment on va
y arriver collectivement le côté positif
en fait que qui est pas abordé là mais
voilà et c'était Grand Corps Malade
merci je propose qu'on diffuse cette
chanson à chaque COP en début à chaque
début de Cop ça pourrait être une idée
le message est lancé merci toutes les
langues d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans politique à table merci à che
Françoise qui nous a fourni ces petits
plat comme d'habitude délicieux merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
[Musique]
LCP cher Petitfils j'ai vu ton courrier
avec
effro